I've been trying to alternate between
ins and strategies we've been using for
these so we master all them so I think
today we're up to a quadrant ethics I
hear the previous time you didn't mean
trash right so Before we jump into the
quadrants the first thing I need is to
get like a base angle and acute angle
that goes with this equation how do i
get that between nor and 90 i'm going to
get an answer how do i how do i find it
we do something with this sign first get
rid of it get rid of it I just need no
sign x equals route 302 that's an exact
value in fact these are all exact values
what's the angle between 9 and 19 that
will give me Simon that angles your
throat too and remember 60 degrees very
good so CC degrees is the ambon would
have you playing with then I say sine is
negative so which quadrants am i
interested in one two three four three
four three four you can see there where
sine is negative so I think what does 60
degrees look like in each of these
quadrants right so I'm going to say in
the third quadrant in the third quadrant
what do I do with the base angle it's
180 or very close it's 180 because I've
got to go 180 degrees and go a little
further to get into the third quadrant
it's going to be 180 plus yeah so 180
plus 60 and then in the fourth quadrant
I come all the way around 360 s where I
end and then I come back with right 360
take away 60 okay you can verify that on
the graph as well so my two answers are
going to be
good morning 240 or 300 there and you
can check it out you get your newly
invented so you can square it you get
three quarters so it's ripped all right
again quickly close x equals 102 so this
is kind of handy because when I look
back at my quadrants which quadrants are
my after for this one first it's
positive right first involved first and
fourth okay what's the base angle that
goes with this guy it's going to be 45
degrees so what does that look like in
the first and fourth quadrants the first
quadrant ed is just 45 ok we just did a
fourth quadrant angle right what do I do
with the fourth quadrant 360 take away
ok so again here's my two solutions 45
or 315 ok now last one I i pointed out
to you I put this in red because it's a
little bit sneaky you're probably not
going to meet many questions like this
you know recently but number one you
will meet them eventually go to you and
number two you totally know enough to
solve the question ok let's just start
the way we did before we say 10 x equals
the sky we'll start by finding our basic
bears I ignore the sign to find the base
angle right so if i do you get a
calculator tan inverse of 1 over root 3
or if you remember the exact value what
do you get out of that 30 degrees that
agrees is my base angle ok now here's a
point where the quadrants are going to
start to let you down you can still
solve this by quadrants but starts to
get confusing I'm going to bore myself I
really could graph good morning ok now
i'm used to drawing my side and cos and
tan graphs and going north to 360 you
can see i drawn the negative part over
here because i don't want to go not to
360 i'm going to go minus 1 h 1 h so i'm
going in both directions negative and
positive ok so there's negative pairs
positive i know what the positive side
looks like it's going to look like that
ok so when i say 30 degrees where where
does this fit it's going to be 180 minus
30 degrees so there will be my first
solution but i would normally say ooh
one two three four quadrants which
questions to my off done I want tend to
be negative right it's going to be
second and fourth second and fourth
which angle have I already found which
solution I found the second quadrant
solution right there's one quadrant
there's the next one not 2 99 180 so I
have my second quadrant angle but I have
a fourth quadrant that goes this way and
in fact my line my graph should be going
that way i'll do it in another color see
you could indicate this is the negative
side right so a graph he is far more
powerful because i can literally put on
there's minus 180 and there's 18 so if
i'm expecting one of my solutions should
be over here that's 150
these pagans 180 take away 30 when will
the other so should be there's one of
them the previous one is going to be
that way 180 degrees right why is it 180
do you remember why I'm donating with 10
yeah fantastic 10 in fact all these
graphs they repeat every so many degrees
for these guys it's 364 10 it's 180 and
we leave at that point when I graphed it
with you on the screen right so it's
going to be puri on it so I can go back
180 degrees from here 150 take away 180
it's going to be negative right be
negative 30 yeah maybe fit okay so
there's my two solutions the graphical
solution does give it to you a little
more cleanly and clearly so I think you
can see why when you put that line
across minus 1 over 3 and get the two
solutions all right let's finish with
some more recent skills here wow I'm
running out of space let's try this Phi
X so you have a look at this guy and
you've got two situations here we know
two rules for finding unknown sides and
triangles like this look up saying rule
we've got the cosine rule which one is
which go for the special part okay this
first one is because I roll and if you
weren't sure how to identify that right
you look at the information that you've
got the cosine rule it means two sides
and an included angle included as it
gets between the two sides that you've
been given so that's why I can use the
cosine rule will get to the sign room
for the last question in a second so
therefore i'm just going to quote the
cosine rule C squared equals I start
like this because it reminds me of which
are the rule that we don't Pythagoras
very good and then I adjust this
adjustment is what makes the cosine rule
the curse on you and it works
non right angwin flavors which is
awesome okay so therefore now that i've
got this i'm just going to punch in
right so x is what I want to find so
that's why it goes over there on the
left and then I fit in my other two
sides and the included angle so I've got
14 squared 17 squared 14 x 17 cause a
hundred and twelve you happy with that
this in calculator work you get in there
you're going to evaluate it you're going
to take the square root someone got the
answer to one decimal place already 20
25.8 35.8 yeah don't check one in check
um see if you can work out let's just
check does that make sense that is just
what I put it does that seem like a
reasonable on top but you have a look at
the original diagram is that that what
you'd expect I think so it's into my
ballpark for starters it's not like a
hundred or a thousand sort of like that
and see how these signs they're going to
be shorter than this one because you've
got a big angle over here that widens
out the triangle so you can expect that
that's long ok I think that sounds good
right just lastly squeeze it in them to
hear impression fine which role are we
going to use it's the Cyril and how do
we know it's the side room yes 23.2 hmm
is your calculator in the right mode
didn't we check that before is that the
answer you got as well I'm with 705 ok I
am pretty sure it won't be 17.5 because
it that doesn't look right 23.2 does
look in the right ballpark so being it
we've got a couple of people who have
this and it is check your numbers here
make sure your brackets aren't funny and
your calculator hasn't done something
unusual in there and then tend to square
root okay we'll check it a bit later
alright it's a sign rule why is it the
same rule have look the information
you've got not the color yeah two angles
and um one side and the other one that's
unknown right another way you can see it
is you pair of a sign with an angle and
then you pair up the other side with
enable and that cross
patent is what gives you the same okay
so therefore we use the same are a
little bit i'm going to jump straight in
i'm going to skip the formula what am I
going to write in the top left on this
faction yep x because i want for find X
right if I can use the right car x and I
match it up with sign the opposite angle
right fantastic so I am 53 and then I'm
going to do the other okay I guess it's
really important like there this is the
demonstration for us as teachers and
markers the student not only knows the
same rule but they know how to use it in
this particular situation okay that's
why writing down a rule doesn't get you
anything but writing down the room with
the right pieces in it shows you how to
interpret the diagram okay so you're
going to bring that sign 53 over again a
bit of calculator work someone got it to
one that's in place 10.6 does it sound
right so look about right yeah I think
it matches up okay do I need to worry
about the ambiguous case for side cuz
got a big use case room do I need to
worry about it I don't I don't why did I
to worry about it it's because I'm on
two things number one it's because I'm
what I'm finding right I'm finding a
length not an angle ok so being an funny
like you don't get this ambiguity
because you're not doing sine inverse at
any point like you're not trying to
solve one of these equations okay so
there's the first reason then secondly
it matches up with your diagram right
you're like yeah that's exactly what I
would SPECT for that kind of side its
opposite of big angle it's going to get
a bigger leg okay